[Música]
y en directo a vamos a México donde
desde ayer lunes Hasta mañana miércoles
avanza la Cumbre de los Tree amigos los
mandatarios de Canadá Estados Unidos y
México que se reúnen con miras a lograr
acuerdos en temas de inmigración
economía y lucha contra el narcotráfico
vamos a la capital Ciudad de México con
nuestro corresponsal Mario carbonel
Mario muy buenas noches cuéntenos cuáles
fueron estos acuerdos en materia
económica
Así es concluyó ya aquí en Palacio
Nacional en la Ciudad de México la
Cumbre de líderes de América del Norte
tras un mensaje a medios que se prolongó
más de lo esperado comenzó con hora y
media de retraso pero en el que se
abordaron distintos temas y ciertamente
el tema económico ha sido uno de los más
importantes se anunció la creación de un
comité integrado por funcionarios de los
tres países para diseñar una estrategia
de sustitución de importaciones El
objetivo dijeron Es que aquí en
Norteamérica se produzca lo que aquí se
consume cuatro funcionarios de cada país
integrarán este que diseñará estas
estrategias también el Primer Ministro
énfasis en que si bien el tratado
comercial México Estados Unidos y Canadá
ha funcionado es necesario reforzar las
cadenas de suministro y para ello
trabajarán de manera conjunta por
ejemplo en el tema de los
semiconductores y también en la creación
de economías limpias es decir dejar
atrás paulatinamente el uso de Carbón y
los combustibles fósiles dijeron que el
producto interno bruto en conjunto de la
región de Norteamérica es mayor al de la
Unión Europea por lo que hay mucho
potencial para convertirse en el área
más próspera del planeta
Mario y qué dijeron por ejemplo en temas
como la migración
Así es sin duda el tema de la migración
fue uno de los más ampliamente abordados
en este mensaje a medios el presidente
biden dijo que desde que llegó a la
administración su preocupación es
ordenar los flujos migratorios por esto
Este programa de ampliar las visas
humanitarias a países de Cuba de Haití y
también de Nicaragua el programa que
originalmente estaba pensado para los
venezolanos agradeció al presidente
López Obrador la decisión de aceptar a
miles de inmigrantes que llegan a la
frontera de México con Estados Unidos y
que no cumplen con los requisitos en su
oportunidad López Obrador también le
insistió al presidente biden en que
impulse en que siga
reiterando la necesidad ante el congreso
de su país de regularizar a los millones
de mexicanos que desde hace años viven y
trabajan en Estados Unidos en Estados
Unidos y que contribuyen al desarrollo
de esa nación agradeció también el
presidente perdón el Primer Ministro
Justin trudea el otorgar 25 visas de
trabajo temporales para mexicanos
también hizo un reconocimiento a Joe
biden por ser el primer presidente
estadounidense en mucho tiempo que no
Construye un solo metro de muro
fronterizo este son parte de los temas
que se abordaron en una reunión en la
que se expresó mucha cordialidad se
dirigieron unos a otros como amigos
países vecinos y que pues van a
contribuir van a continuar contribuyendo
de manera conjunta al desarrollo y la
prosperidad de la región